Guten Tag, mein Name ist Sumera Firat. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistant Assistant
und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich. Hauptsache, guckt jemand nach mir, ja.
Okay. Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen, bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre aktuellen Bescheiden erzählen, würde ich Ihnen gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie das?
Ich heiße Frank Pfeiffer.
Frank Pfeiffer?
Ja. Könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen langsam und deutlich bestabieren?
Ja, der Vorname Frank F-R-A-N-K-Frank.
Und Pfeiffer, P-F-E-I-W-F-E-R.
Um sicher zu sein, bestabiere ich noch einmal. Ihr Vorname lautet F-R-A-N-K-Frank.
Ihr Nachname lautet P-F-I-W-I-T-E-W-M-R.
Umgekehrt, E-I.
Okay, ja. Und nach I-Doppel-F-E-R.
Okay, Herr Frank Pfeiffer, spreche ich Ihren Namen richtig aus?
Ja, genau.
Okay, wie alt sind Sie, Herr Pfeiffer?
Ich bin 36 Jahre alt.
36 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 14.09.89.
Okay, 14.09.1989.
Genau.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
Wie viel wiegeln Sie so seit?
So 92 kg.
92 kg.
Okay.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was führt Sie heute so uns, Herr Pfeiffer?
Ja, wissen Sie, mein rechter Bein tut so weh im Unterschenkel.
Das ist auch ganz geschwollen und ist auch gerötet und das spandt auch so.
Das tut mir sehr weh.
Wenn ich laufe, tut es weh.
Wenn ich auch dagegen komme, tut es weh.
Das ist sehr schmerzhaft und das macht mir ein bisschen Angst.
Das tut mir leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben.
Können Sie mir sagen, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, das hat vor zwei Tagen angefangen.
Seit zwei Tagen angefangen.
Am Anfang habe ich gedacht, es kommt und geht wieder.
Aber es wird immer schlechter.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Bis man es merkt, dauert es immer eine kleine Weile.
Dann waren Sie mit einmal da.
Die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Ja, ja.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Ja, das hat angefangen.
Ich war lange mit dem Auto unterwegs.
Ich bin auf einer Messe gewesen und bin dann lange zurückgefahren.
Es gab viele Staus und Unfälle auf der Strecke.
Dadurch hat sich die Fahrt so hingezogen.
Ich habe kurz Pause gemacht, aber ich war so sieben Stunden im Auto.
Danach fing es eigentlich so richtig an.
Nach lange Autofahren ist das plötzlich aufgetreten.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala
von 1 bis 10 vorbei?
Ein leichter Schmerz, ein sehr starker Schmerz.
Das tut schon toll weh.
Vor allem, wenn man dagegen kommt, das ist schon sehr druckempfunglich.
Vielleicht so, bei 7 oder so.
Das ist so stark.
Können Sie die Schmerzen bis zum Ende das Gesprech aushalten?
Ja, wenn ich jetzt nicht rumlaufe, dann tut es ja auch nicht so schlimm weh.
Super. Ich versuche schnell so beendet.
Die Schmerzen sind drückend.
Ja, drückend. Wie kann man die noch beschreiben?
Drückend und vielleicht auch so ein bisschen stechend.
Stechend auch.
Beim Laufen sind die Schmerzen stärker.
Gibt es noch andere Dinge, die die Schmerzen verstärken?
Nein, das wüsste ich nicht.
Ein bisschen besser wird es, wenn ich es hochlege.
Aber wenn ich es wieder runter mache, dann schießt es wieder so rein.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Hochlägerung hilft ein bisschen.
Herr Faifa, strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwohin aus, zum Beispiel nach oben oder bis zum Fuß?
Ja, die Hauptsache ist im Unterchenkel, aber strahlt bis in die Kniekehle rein.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass ihr Unterchenkel geschwollen, gerötet ist.
Ist die Unterchenkel auf überwarmt?
Mutlich. Ich denke, das fühlt sich schon warm an.
Und wenn es mir aufgefallen ist, die Haut glänzt so richtig.
Ja, das ist ganz prall alles.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Haben Sie eine Type-Heiß- oder Kribbelsgefühl an der rechten Unterchenkel bemerkt?
Nein, das tut eigentlich nicht. Es tut nur weh.
Herr Faifa, haben Sie Fieber?
Also, ich habe heute Nacht unheimlich geschwitzt. Ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber ich denke, könnte gut sein.
Ja, natürlich werde ich beide Köpfe alle unter der Temperatur gemessen.
Aber Sie schwitzen sehr?
In der Nacht habe ich geschwitzt, ja.
Seit zwei Tagen auch?
Ja, genau, da fing das an.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Leiden Sie unter Brustschmerzen, Luftnot, Herzrasen oder Engegefühl?
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Also, ich habe nur in Beinen die Schmerzen.
Nur Beine-Schmerzen? Ja, verstehe ich.
Herr Faifa, ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen in Ihrer Allgemeinen Zustand schiessen.
Haben Sie Übelkeit?
Nein, also Übelkeit nicht. Was mir aufgefallen ist, das Essen schmeckt mir gerade nicht so richtig die Tage.
Aber Übel ist nicht, also ich muss mich nicht übergeben oder so, nein, gar nicht.
Es ist alles nur das Feintut, wie hier.
Okay, verstehe ich. Ja, das ist eine gute Zeichen. Wie ist es mit dem Stullgang? Alles in Ordnung?
Na ja, also da habe ich schon seit längerer Zeit eine gewisse Problematik.
Also, man hat festgestellt, dass ich Zolliakie habe.
Ich muss also beim Essen tatsächlich sehr aufpassen.
Sonst, wenn ich das nicht mache, habe ich Probleme mit Durchfall.
Aber wenn ich schön Diät halte, dann geht es mir gut.
Momentan haben Sie keine Durchfall? Nein, weil ich eigentlich immer sehr konsequent achte, dass ich keinen Gluten esse.
Ja, super. Ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser? Nein, nein.
Okay, ja.
Jetzt ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen, so ihr erfolge ich das.
Außer Zolliakunverträglichkeit, haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Blutochterung oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Sie sind schon sehr jung, aber vielleicht haben Sie...
Ja, das habe ich vor fünf Jahren schon festgestellt, so eine Hashimoto-Schilddrüsenerkrankung.
Und ich muss halt regelmäßig Ultirox nehmen.
Okay, kennen Sie Dosierung?
Ich meine, das sind hundert. Dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Ganz eine Tablette, ein hundert Mikro.
Außer Hashimoto und Zolliakunverträglichkeit gibt es keine chronische Erkrankungen.
Ich habe eigentlich oft zu tun mit so Nebenhöhlen.
Wenn ich das habe, dann muss ich halt irgendwelche Medikamente nehmen, die das auflösen.
Und dann habe ich eigentlich gute Erfahrungen gemacht mit Gelomirtolkapseln.
Die nehme ich dann, die muss ich mir halt in der Apotheke kaufen.
Aber die nehme ich halt, bevor es schlimmer wird.
Okay, verstehe. Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Nein, in meinem Leben bisher noch nicht, nein.
Okay, super. Außer Erdroxin und Gelomirtolkapseln.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente, Beibedarf oder regelmäßig ein?
Ja, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe oder so, dann nehme ich schon mal Aspirin oder so.
Aspirin. Kennen Sie Dosierung?
Na ja, also ich glaube, das sind so den 500er Aspirin und ja, gegen Kopfschmerzen oder so.
Ja, Herr Faifa, haben Sie schon eine Medikamente gegen Irschmerzen angenommen?
Seit drei Tagen?
Ich habe tatsächlich mal zwei Tage lang Aspirin eingenommen, ja.
Okay. Wie viel?
Zweimal, zweimal je eine Tablette, ja.
Zweimal, täglich.
Hat das Ihnen geholfen?
Nicht wirklich, also das Bein ist ja trotzdem dick und vielleicht sind die Schmerzen ein bisschen weniger geworden, aber letztendlich merke ich ja, dass mit dem Bein das nicht in Ordnung ist.
Ja, okay, verstehe. Bezüglich Ihrer Beschwerden habe ich noch andere Fragen.
Haben Sie sich Ihren Unterschenkel verletzt?
Nein, nein, nein, ich bin nur ganz normal Auto gefahren und ich hatte keinen Unfall und bin in so viel, ich weiß auch nirgendwo angestoßen oder so.
Ja, okay. Sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas, Herr Faifa?
Ja, also diese Glutengeschichte natürlich, ja. Und ich darf auch kein Novalvine nehmen.
Da bekomme ich so heftigen Ausschlag davon.
Okay, Hautauschlag.
Ja, ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Gewohnheit stellen. Rauchen Sie, Herr Faifa?
Oh, seit fünf Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr. Ich bin sehr stolz, dass ich das geschafft habe, aber ich habe auch nie so richtig viel geraucht.
Ich habe eigentlich immer nur so zehn Zigaretten am Tag geraucht und auch nicht so furchtbar lange.
Insofern fühlen mir das mit dem Aufhören nicht so furchtbar schwer.
Ja, ich kritisiere Ihnen. Das ist eine Grundentscheidung für Ihre Gesundheit. Sie haben aber sehr kurze Zeit,
Sägen, Zigarette täglich geraucht.
Ja, das war ungefähr so zehn Jahre lang.
Und gefassene Jahre lang. Ja, okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ich trinke gerne abends ein Glas Wein, so zum Feierabend. Doch das trinke ich auch schon ziemlich regelmäßig.
Okay, Sie trinken, ja, der Abend ein Glas Wein.
Kann man so sagen, ja.
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie mir Ihre nächste Frage nicht, Uwe. Das ist eine Routinefrage. Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Drogen?
Die Zeiten sind vorbei. Ja, als junger Mann, da habe ich mal haschisch probiert und da gab es mal so eine Zeit, wo ich ziemlich viel,
ja, oder ziemlich viel, aber hin und wieder sagen, wenn mal ein Joint geraucht habe, aber das ist schon lange vorbei.
Okay, super. Das freut mich.
Ja, jetzt, ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie Geschichte stellen. Sind Ihre Eltern gesund oder gibt es chronische Erkrankungen bei Ihren Eltern?
Ja, mein Vater ist leider recht schwer erkrankt. Der ist ja noch nicht wirklich sehr alt.
Der hatte vor so einem Viertel, ja, hatte eine Darmooperation. Da musste ein Stück entfernt werden. Der hatte Darmkrips und der hat einen künstlichen Ausgang bekommen.
Und wir hoffen natürlich, dass der irgendwann noch wieder zurückverdicht werden kann. Aber im Augenblick hat er also noch diesen künstlichen Ausgang und ja, das ist natürlich schwer für ihn.
Ja, das tut mir leid für mich. Okay, bezüglich Ihrer Mutter ist sie gesund?
Ja, grundlegend. Also so organisch ist die Gesundheit hat nur ein bisschen Probleme mit ihren Kniegelenken.
Welche Probleme hat sie? Wissen Sie?
Ja, das ist wohl irgendwie Arthrose oder so in den Gelenken.
Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war Einzelkind.
Einzelkind. Okay. Ja, Hi, Hi, Hi. Was sind Sie von Beiruf?
Ja, ich leite das Geschäft meiner Eltern weiter. Wir haben ein großes Modegeschäft hier am Ort und ich bin auch viel selber im Verkauf.
Und deswegen muss ich natürlich viel stehen und es kommt mir jetzt gar nicht zu passen, dass das Bein so weh tut, ja.
Ja, das kann schwer für Sie. Ja, verstehe. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben einen kleinen Sohn.
Ein kleine Sohn, ja, das ist es. Ist er gesund?
Ja, der ist quitschgesund, ja.
Okay, machen Sie Sport regelmäßig oder treiben Sie Sport?
Ich versuche es hin und wieder, aber ja, das ist sehr schwer, da dran zu bleiben.
Ja, wenn es im Sommer fahre ich ganz gerne Fahrrad und manchmal gehe ich so zum Fitness-Training, aber das schaffe ich nicht sehr oft.
Nein, nicht regelmäßig, aber fast regelmäßig. Nein, nicht regelmäßig, nein.
Okay, verstehe. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich musste natürlich klar mich impfen gegen Corona und ich habe auch die Grippeimpfung jedes Jahr jetzt immer mitgemacht, weil ich ja viel Kundenkontakt habe.
Okay, super. Ja, Herr Pfeiffer, möchte Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, das sind eigentlich ja, Sie haben jetzt schon so viel gefragt, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen kann.
Okay, Herr Pfeiffer, wir sind jetzt mit dem Gespräch fertig.
Ich werde jetzt eine Köperleuntersuchung machen, dann Blut für das Lebe abnehmen und Ihre Ultraschall, Ihre Beine, Ihre Beine durchführen.
Sobald Ihre von der Vorlage bespricht, ich Ihre Situation mit meinem Oberarzt, dann komme ich zu Ihnen, Egläreenen, alles schirrt, wurscht.
Und auch, was wir gegen die Schmerzen tun können?
Ja, natürlich. Sie möchten, kann ich sofort reinschmerzen.
Okay, ja.
Bitte warte Sie hier, ich komme gleich.
Ja, danke.
Hat jemand noch zusätzliche Fragen von Ihnen?
Nein, offensichtlich war das sehr vollständig, ja, Sie waren sehr spraedt und Sie haben auch nicht die Zeit.
Reiseanalyse hat ja eigentlich gesagt, dass er gerade gefahren ist.
Insofern übrigt sich eigentlich eine weitere Frage, oder ja, man hätte noch Fragen können, waren Sie im Ausland oder so, ja, aber war er nicht.
Ja, Sie sagen einfach Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind, Frau Dr. Fierhardt.
Ja?
Ja, okay, wir können anfangen.
Sie können schon anfangen?
Ja.
Ja, schon, alles klar.
Ja, manchmal versuche ich, während der Vorschtellung, ja, denke ich, was ich sage.
Ja, ich meine, das war auch eine sehr breite Spur, die ich hier gelegt habe, ja.
Also, gut, fangen wir an.
Okay, guten Tag, Frau Oberarztin.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Es geht um Herr Frank Pfeiffer.
Er ist 36 Jahre alt und am 14., 14., 19. 1989 geboren.
Er ist 1 Meter 84 groß und wiegt 92 Kilogramm.
Er stellt sich bei uns wegen seit 3 Tagen bestehende rechte Unterschenkelschmerzen vor.
Laut Aussage des Patienten sind die Schmerzen plötzlich nach längeres Autofahrens angefangen.
Nach einer längeren Autofahrt?
Nein, Autofahrt.
Okay.
Nach einer längeren Autofahrt?
Nein, Autofahrt.
Autofahrt, okay.
Langeren Autofahrt.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen drückend, stehend, persisterend, progredient sind.
Die Schmerzen sind in der Intensität von 7,10 auf der Schmerzkala.
Und die Schmerzen verschlimmern sich beim Stehen und laufen,
während sie sich bei Hochlaagerung besser.
Und er erwähnt, dass die Unterschenkel geschwollen, gerötet und überwandt sind.
Und die Haut sieht glanzend prall aus.
Und er begleitet, klagt über, umgemessen, fieber und hydro nachschweißt.
Ja, vegetative Anamnestisch war unauffällig.
Bei der Feuerkranken Anamnese erwähnte er Hašimota seit 5 Jahren.
Und Sennositis, residuerende Sennositis und Söljakie.
Bei der Medikamenten Anamnese ergab sich die Einnahme von El Troxin 100 Mikrogramm,
einmal Morganz, Aspirin 500 Milligramm bei Bedarf und Glometolkapsel gegen Sennositis bei Bedarf.
Die allergenen Anamnese war unauffällig, bis auf allergenen Neuwalgen, die sich exantem oysert.
Die Noxin Anamnese ergab circa 5 Packers bis vor 5 Jahren und ein Glas Wein jede Abend.
Die Familien Anamnese ergab, Kolon Karstino bei Fatah, Gona Artros, bei der Mutah.
Sozial Anamnestisch ist er selbstständig, er leitet eine Mode geschafft.
Er ist verheiratet, hat einen Sohn und er versucht, Sport zu treiben, leider nicht regelmäßig.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf, tiefe Venostrombose hin.
Das könnte es differenzial diagnostisch unter Umstand noch sein?
Eigentlich. Ich habe gefragt, um eine Differenzialdiagnose zu finden, vielleicht hat er einen Unfall.
Das hat er verneint.
Er hat keinen Unfall gehabt.
Was könnte differenzialdiagnostisch zur Trombose geben?
Es gibt eigentlich zwei Sachen, die man vermuten könnte.
Leider habe ich keine Differenzialdiagnose.
Es könnte nur eine Tromboflebitis sein?
Ja, Tromboflebitis oder Vorecoce.
Oder es könnte auch sein, wenn er eine kleine Wunde hat, was er verneint hat.
Dann könnte es auch ein Irresipel sein.
Das wären noch diese Differenzialdiagnose.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Diagnostisch werde ich natürlich auch eine Erskörperle-Untersuchung machen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der Inspektion achte ich Schwellung, Rötung und glanzende Preilhaute.
Und bei Pallpassion auf Überwahl.
Überwärmung?
Ja.
Was machen Sie noch mit Ihren Händen?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Natürlich Puls.
Bei den Händen und auch bei Pulse.
Nur an den Krankenbein?
Nein, ich muss vergleichen.
Ja, das ist entscheidend.
Die Fußpulse im Vergleich.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch noch bei der ersten körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bevor Sie zu irgendeinem Gerät greifen und bevor Sie Labor abnehmen.
Bevor Labor und bevor...
Bevor Labor noch und vor dem Doppler.
Was machen Sie noch?
Das haben Sie schon gemacht.
Das gehe ich davon aus, dass der Mensch noch lebt.
Es gibt die klassischen Tromposezeichen.
Hormonsweiche?
Jawoll.
Es gibt Hormons.
Es gibt wen noch?
Ich weiß nur Hormons.
Paya, Maya, Hormon.
Paya ist Fußsohn-Druckschmerz.
Maya ist Waden-Kompressionsschmerz.
Und Hormon ist Waden-Druckschmerz bei Dorsalexpension.
Paya, Maya, Hormon.
Jawoll, da haben wir sie alle.
Ja, genau.
Gut, ja, was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Im Labor werde ich Blutbild, Einzündungparameter,
Gerundungsparameter.
Der DEMA ist sehr wichtig.
Jawoll, genau.
Und Nirm, Labor, Elektroliut, Bechtung.
Ja.
Gut.
Was ist eigentlich das Entscheidende?
Ja, DEMA.
Ja, der DEMA-Wert, da braucht man eigentlich dann nicht weiter
etwas anderes zu machen, das wissen wir Bescheid.
Genau.
Aber Sie machen noch was?
Im Labor.
Nein, nicht so.
Als Apparativ werde ich natürlich duplegsonografie.
Jawoll.
Das unter Schenkels, rechts unter Schenkels,
vornehmend, durschüren.
Und was erwarten Sie zu sehen?
Beide duplersonografie erwerte ich
Veranderung der Blutgeschwindigkeit
und auch eine Staun.
Eine Staun? Jawoll.
Gut.
Und ja, wenn sich Ihre Diagnose bestätigt,
wenn also das Dopplerbild und der DEMA-Wert
zusammenpassen, was ist denn dann die angesagte Therapie?
Ja, die Patienten sollten stationär aufgenommen werden.
Okay.
Und ich werde den Patienten natürlich eine
so trombose Lösung, ein Medikament,
auch so trombose, um trombose zu vermeiden,
werde ich auf trombosit Aggregation HEMA verabschieden.
Ja, nämlich, was zum Beispiel?
Wie Heparin.
Und natürlich Langfristige empfehle ich aspirin.
Nur aspirin?
Ich weiß gar nicht, Langfristige.
Ja, ich glaube, Langfristige,
also muss ich fragen, was Sie unter Langfristig verstehen.
Ja, ich denke, Langfristige müsste man entweder was machen.
Ja, Langfristig.
Also das nächste halbe Jahr.
Ja, das ist normal.
Im Normalfall ist ja eigentlich keine OP erforderlich.
Also die compressionstüpfel?
Die brauchen wir auf alle Fälle, ja, natürlich, ja.
Aber man braucht ja nach einer Trombose,
also zunächst mal heparinisiert man,
aber was ist der nächste Schritt?
Dann so erscheben wir Heparin.
Und dann verandern wir trombose Aggregation HEMA,
wie Varkuma, oder?
Varkuma, genau, ja, richtig.
Hatten Sie schon gesagt, ich habe, dann habe ich das immer gehört.
Nein, ich habe nicht, ja, früher habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ach so, okay.
Jetzt, wenn Sie gefragt haben, habe ich.
Ja, ja, genau, das ist genau der Punkt.
Darauf wollte ich raus, Varkuma.
Und es gibt heute noch modernere trombose Aggregation HEMA.
Ja, direkt Aggregation, direkt Oral Antikapiazon,
Apixapan und so weiter.
Ja, genau.
Gut, und ja, Sie haben den Strumpf erwähnt.
Den Strumpf haben Sie erwähnt, den Kompressionsstrumpf?
Ja, ich habe erwähnt.
Ja, gut.
Wie lange muss der Patient den tragen?
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Halbis Jahr.
Und danach, also bevor er abgesetzt wird, bevor Varkuma bzw.
der Trombose Aggregation HEMA und Kompressionsstrumpf abgesetzt
werden, muss eine duplexsonographische Kontrolle erfolgen.
Okay.
Und wie lange muss denn der Kompressionsstrumpf sein?
Von wo bis wo?
Ja, ich glaube,
von fersen bis über Knie.
Also bis zum Oberschenkel.
Genau, abes G.
Ja, der braucht, also nicht nur einen Kniestrumpf,
weil er es im Unterschenkel hat,
der braucht es für das ganze Bein.
Also einen langen Strumpf.
Und den muss er eben solange tragen.
Und wenn der jetzt den Strumpf noch nicht angepasst hat,
solange er das Bein noch geschwollen ist,
dann muss der Strumpf ja nicht angepasst werden.
Was machen wir da?
Dann vielleicht Operation kann.
Nein, nein.
Konservativ, statt Strumpf.
Ganz einfach.
Kompressionsverband.
Der Strumpf muss ja angepasst werden.
Der kann aber ja nicht am geschwollenen Bein angepasst werden.
Ja, sonst misst das Landitätshaus
und der geschwollene Bein aus
und der passt nachher nicht mehr.
Also muss man erstmal das Bein abschwellen.
Das heißt, ja klar Hochlagerung,
gut, ja, guter Hinweis,
Hochlagerung des Beins
und Bandageierung.
Ja, Kompressionsbandageierung von vorne,
von der Fußspitze, also vom Fuß bis zum Oberschenkel.
So lange bis das Bein abgeschwollen muss.
Jawohl, gut.
Ja, ich habe nicht
so viel Meinung über
tiefwein Trombose.
Bei Düsseldorf haben wir keine tiefwein Trombose
und deswegen
seit einem Monat
habe ich nicht beschäftigt mit anderen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Deswegen weiß ich nicht genau,
wie können wir
tiefwein Trombose behandeln oder
diagnostizieren.
Aber wie sagt man so schön, sie lernen ja nicht
für die Prüfung, sie lernen ja fürs Leben.
Und es kann ihnen ja durchaus passieren,
dass ihnen irgendwann mal ein Trombose-Panzier über den Weg läuft.
Und dann ist es gut zu wissen, was zu tun ist.
Ja, natürlich.
Nur möchte ich
erwähnen.
Bei dieser
Gespräche habe ich viel gelernt.
Deswegen freut mich sehr.
Sie wissen vielleicht nicht,
ich habe die letzten Jahre meiner Berufstätigkeit
im gefälschlichen Sekretariat gearbeitet.
Deswegen
ist mir
dieses Thema
eben so geläufig.
Das war immer die Diagnose,
wo man auf alle Fälle sofort einen Termin vergeben musste.
Wenn die Leute gesagt haben,
mein Hausarzt hat gesagt, Verdacht auch,
Trombose, dann kommen sie halt vorbei.
Und sonst mussten die immer lange warten.
Gut, es kam gerade ein guter Hinweis.
Die Sprache
wird tatsächlich mehr bewertet,
als das Wissen in der Prüfung.
Sie müssen ja nicht jeden Fall kennen.
Ich fand es interessant,
Sie haben sich mitgehört, der Kollege, der kürzlich in Dresden
seine Prüfung hatte,
so etwas Exotisches bekommen,
der hat einen dermatologischen Fall bekommen.
Das finde ich wirklich abgefahren.
Der hat aber die Prüfung bestanden,
weil er sprachlich unheimlich gut ist.
Genauso wird es bei Ihnen auch sein.
Sie sind sprachlich, ganz souverän unterwegs.
Was mir heute auch gefallen ist,
ist wirklich eine kleine Winzigkeit.
Das Verb steht an zweiter Stelle.
Das ist so ein, sage ich,
ungefähr jedes zweite Mal.
Jetzt ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Jetzt ich werde, das und das machen.
Jetzt ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Zwei Mal haben Sie es, glaube ich, richtig gemacht.
Und zweimal haben Sie es falsch gemacht.
Jetzt werde ich Ihnen noch...
Diese Einleitung finde ich eigentlich immer sehr schön,
dass Sie sagen, ich habe jetzt noch ein Thema,
über das wir auch sprechen müssen.
Dann habe ich noch eine Sache gehabt.
Sie haben zur Noxenanalyse.
Haben Sie zwar das Nichtrauchen
oder das, die die fünf Päckiers erwähnt
und den Wein, aber Sie haben,
obwohl der hat endlich mal ein Patient ist,
der etwas zur Drogen gesagt hat,
haben Sie das der Oberärzte nicht gesagt,
dass der früher mal haschisch geraucht hat?
Ja, Sie haben es nicht.
Ich habe mein Papier notiert.
Das ist wahrscheinlich für diese Therapie
und für die Diagnose jetzt nicht relevant.
Nur das ist ja endlich mal ein Patient,
dass es einen Konsum zugibt.
Ja, gut.
Das ist diese Geschichte.
Dann bin ich immer so ein bisschen skeptisch,
wenn man sagt,
Allergieanalyse ist unauffällig bis auf.
Nee, also...
Auf die Frage nach Allergen
gibt er an, dass er auf Neuvalgien mit Auslag reagiert
und dann die Glutenunverträglichkeit
ist durch die Zoleakia schon erwähnt gewesen.
Jawohl.
Also auch, ich finde,
auch immer, wenn jemand
zwei Symptome sagt, die
zur vegetative Analyse,
die eigentlich nicht in Ordnung sind,
dann ist die nicht mehr unauffällig,
sondern die vegetative Analyse ergabt
bei diesem Patienten
Nachtschweiß und Appetitlosigkeit.
Das müsste man schon
und dann ist sie eigentlich nicht unauffällig.
Gut.
Bei der vegetative Analyse habe ich vergessen,
Gewicht oder Appatit-Suchstand zu fragen.
Aber nachher habe ich...
Er hat das selber gesagt.
Als Sie nach Übelkeit gefragt haben,
hat er gesagt,
Übel ist mir nicht, aber ich habe eigentlich
keinen guten Appetit in diesen Tagen.
Und...
Gewicht haben Sie tatsächlich nicht gefragt,
das stimmt, ob sich das reduziert hat.
Aber das wäre ja auch ehrlich gesagt eine idiotische Frage.
Innerhalb von zwei Tagen,
was soll da passieren?
Das fand ich auch auffällig.
Sie haben gesagt, er hat seit drei Tagen Schmerzen im Rechen
unterschägt.
Aber dann korrigiere ich mich selbst.
Okay, besser drei Tage.
Gut.
Und nachher, diese ganzen Untersuchungen,
Labor war alles einwandfrei, Pulse kamen,
ja dann,
Paella, Homa und Maya, das sollte man vielleicht auf dem Schirm haben,
wenn nicht für die Prüfung, dann fürs Leben.
Ja, heute habe ich gelernt.
Und Therapie,
erst niederekulare Heparin
und dann Markomarisierung
und so lange weiter Heparin, bis der
normalwert erreicht hat.
INR, ne?
Ja, mit INR sollen wir überprüfen.
Ja, und...
und Kompressionen, das ist wichtig.
Und stationäre Aufnahme
ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen Glaubenssache.
Ich glaube eigentlich, dass man das heute nicht mehr macht.
Dass man tatsächlich nicht mehr alle Trombosen stationär aufnimmt.
Man schickt sie nur mit einer ganz dringenden Maßgabe nach Hause.
Dass man sagt,
sobald sie auch nur die geringsten Anzeichen haben
von Atemnot,
müssen sie sofort wiederkommen.
Ja, das ist eigentlich die Geschichte.
Und sie haben da,
sie haben da ja zwar kurz nachgefragt,
haben sie Herzprobleme oder Probleme beim Atmen.
Der hat ja gesagt, weit und weh, was habe ich da oben?
Aber sie wussten natürlich ganz genau,
Lungenembolie ist die Komplikation,
die man im Auge behalten muss.
Doch, also sprachlich sind sie immer wieder
wirklich sehr gut aufgestellt
und sie müssen sich wirklich für ihre Prüfung
keine Sorgen machen.
Ja, ich hoffe, vielen Dank.
Ja, sehr gut.